you know who's having even no worse week
than us did you guys see that video that
Tiger mauling in China no so I mean I'm
I don't know why I'm laughing it's
really [ __ ] up but look at the video
online some woman I guess gets into an
argument with they go into a safari park
you know we need those safaris where you
cannot you shouldn't even roll your
windows down you just go through it and
they're like wild tigers around you or
whatever she gets into an altercation I
guess with the the other person in the
car she gets out of her car goes to the
passenger side and a [ __ ] tiger just
mauls her like grabs her and carries her
off of the thing and then the second
person who was inside a car goes and
tries to save her she gets mauled by a
second tiger and then gets mauled to
death get out the car they got out of
the [ __ ] car were they in the zoo it
was yeah it's like a zoo but you know
those wildlife safari parks where you've
never been
yeah in Africa I've been doing okay good
yeah well you're not supposed to get out
of the rule number one don't leave the
[ __ ] car like when we're in the Jeep
in Africa they're like there were the
Lions I go well cool I'm not leaving the
car yeah what do they leave again
because they got into an altercation
like let's say you and I were fighting
in the car later [ __ ] you Bobby and
whatever I got out of the car we're not
getting out of the car
no you fight you had a car child luck or
no or just go hey let's take this fight
when there are [ __ ] Tigers around
yeah let's find at the hotel yeah yeah
yeah let's just we tea right because I'm
playing too much destiny right and
whatnot but can you say it when we're
inside a hotel mm-hmm not where there's
[ __ ] Tigers all right you have to
watch the video babe I don't wanna watch
drag did she die the second lady who try
to save her died
oh my Chinese Oh Chinese tip too many I
love what you love it cuz you smile I
didn't smile oh just camera let's do a
that's right
Oh Chinese died
[Music]